septembre 1946
il se souvient d'un premier rendez-vous
me dit pour un non attends c'est 46
moi je me souviens de deux rendez vous
importants que la première fois qu'on a
commencé à parler d'un numéro c'était à
saint-augustin dans un bistrot voilà
sept ans 46 et je me souviens d'une date
un peu plus proche alors enfin quelques
semaines après quand on a commencé le
numéro on a bouffé à l'apache a search
est amer oui à saint thois
d'idées ce qui est chiant là on en a
quand même écrit attaqué j'ai le
répertoire ah ça fait combien ça fait
2008 2009 à peu près tu te souviens de
l'amiral les débuts de l'amiral oh la la
d'abord le patron le patron monsieur
mail qui avait ouvert trois fois au
tabou ainsi à une table tout seul devant
à cognac et qui ne riez pas j'ai fait
messieurs voulez-vous j'aurais vous
parlez côté je vois votre numéro ces
trois fois que je viens pour eux je ne
ris pas je ne comprends rien et autour
de moi les gens s'amusent je vous engage
dans mon cabaret l'amiral tout souviens
il y avait deux entraîneuses et 12 en 13
ans installe
c'était notre premier public aux lieux
publics a été député dire et je me
souviens des clients de l'amiral carré
après alors assuré au début bon et après
un moment
les filles on est obligé de partir parce
qu'il y avait la clientèle ce qui est
arrivé il ya eu dix pièces de sup à 210
d'engouement pour nous dans
l'intelligence cia de l'époque et purent
alors là c'est incroyable ce qu'on a vu
défiler j'ai pu moi il avait taylor prix
john catherine gilleron quatre bornes
et puis alors je me souviens d'un jour
je me suis de trappes et l'on tapait à
20 sketches ont tapé sur des casseroles
on avait distribué dès qu'on distribue
des casseroles aux clients je revois à
une table mais c'est vrai comme des
harengs il y avait françois mauriac le
maréchal juin et bourvil et côte à côte
bourvil et mauriac ne riez pas au même
sketch non c'est vrai hirsch et le un
jour delorme termine daniel de l'oms
indique jean-marc roger je vais vous
amener demain soir jean paul sartre
alors jean paul ça oui oui jean paul
sartre et il n'est pas venu alors après
on dit aux patrons il est pas mais jean
paul sartre et je vais demander aux
chasseurs chasseurs brille n'est pas
venu à monsieur pendant le spectacle
un monsieur comment comme ça un petit
peu rond et des lunettes un peu un peu
un peu curieux il fait aussi un bonhomme
je les vire et pourquoi il a une sale
gueule
je crois qu'on va encore joué longtemps
ensemble comme ça écoute je sais pas
pour l'instant
donc on pourrait en tout cas mais
franchement on écoute je sais pas moi
qu'est ce que tu fais pour
pour l'an 2000 pour un début je ne sais
pas mais en 93 si tu veux oui les
valises sont prêts obama va lui sont
toujours prêtes bon
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le leader
des tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu